guten tag herr grünfeld guten tag herr
grünfeld
guten tag frau osterwalder guten tag
frau osterwalder
wie geht es ihnen wie geht es ihnen
nicht so gut ich bin ein bisschen krank
was haben sie was haben sie
ich habe schnupfen und halsschmerzen
oh je dann sollten sie jetzt ab ins bett
gehen und sich ausruhen
bleiben sie heute zu hause
ja ich gehe heute nicht arbeiten
[Musik]
aber ich muss die wäsche waschen
außerdem sollte ich noch einkaufen
ich gehe in die stadt ich kann die
einkäufe für sie machen
[Musik]
ich gehe in die stadt ich kann die
einkäufe für sie machen
vielen dank das ist sehr nett von ihnen
kann ich ihnen eine liste für die
einkäufe geben
vielen dank das ist sehr nett von ihnen
kann ich ihnen eine liste für die
einkäufe geben
ja sicher brauchen sie auch etwas aus
der apotheke
ich denke nicht ich habe ein neo zitrone
getrunken und ich habe lutschtabletten
nein ich denke nicht ich habe ein neo
zitrone getrunken und ich habe
lutschtabletten
trinken sie viel tee mit zitrone das
hilft sicher
ja das mache ich ja das mache ich
gute besserung
dank
frau osterwalder danke frau osterwalder
gern geschehen
gern
ich komme in einer halben stunde zu
ihnen um die einkaufsliste zu holen
[Musik]
ich komme in einer halben stunde zu
ihnen um die einkaufsliste zu holen
bis später bis später
grüezi guten tag ich möchte gerne etwas
gegen kopfschmerzen
ich möchte gerne etwas gegen
kopfschmerzen
haben sie ein rezept
ein rezept
nein ich habe kein
rezept
nein ich habe kein rezept
haben sie oft kopfschmerzen
nein ich habe eigentlich nie
kopfschmerzen
nehmen sie andere medikamente
ja ich nehme ein medikament gegen meine
arthrose
können sie mir den namen des medikaments
sagen
können sie
den namen des medikaments sagen
schmerzfrei 29
gut dann gebe ich ihnen diese tabletten
nehmen sie alle vier stunden eine
tablette maximal vier pro tag
wie bitte die bitte nehmen sie alle vier
stunden eine tablette
zb eine tablette um 8 uhr
dann eine um 12 uhr
dann eine um 16 uhr
und dann eine um 20 uhr
nehmen sie alle vier stunden eine
tablette
[Musik]
zum beispiel eine tablette um 8 uhr
dann eine um 12 uhr
dann eine um 16 uhr
und dann eine um 20 uhr
nehmen sie maximal vier tabletten pro
tag
ich verstehe
ich schreibe ihnen das auf die packung
ich
ihnen das auf die packung
ich gern danke
möchten sie sonst noch etwas
ja ich möchte gerne noch etwas gegen
halsschmerzen
ich weiß das wort nicht auf deutsch so
tabletten wie bonbons
ich weiß das wort nicht auf deutsch zu
lutschtabletten
sie meinen lutschtabletten
moment
diese lutschtabletten sind sehr gut
nehmen sie maximal fünf pro tag
in ordnung danke
in ordnung danke möchten sie sonst noch
etwas
nein danke das ist alles
das macht zusammen 24 franken 50 bitte
hier bitte hier bitte danke
auf wiedersehen und gute besserung
danke auf wiedersehen
haben sie ein rezept von einem arzt
nein ich habe kein rezept
tut mir leid aber ich
das medikament oder ein rezept von einem
arzt nicht geben
es tut mir leid aber ich kann ihnen das
medikament ohne ein rezept von einem
arzt nicht geben
nicht vergessen dieses video zu liken zu
kommentieren um zu teilen
habt ihr das video gefallen abonniere
unseren kanal hat dir das video gefallen
abonniere unseren kanal